y en france 24 dedicamos a este espacio
a las elecciones en colombia los
ciudadanos acudirán a las urnas el
próximo 13 de marzo donde se van a
elegir a los integrantes de las dos
cámaras del congreso y por primera vez
en la historia de ese país se van a
votar 16 curules a la cámara de
representantes que deben ser ocupadas
por las víctimas del conflicto armado
esto tiene como objetivo la reparación
de los territorios más afectados a
través de la participación política
veamos el siguiente informe que ha
preparado luis muñoz
este sitio es muy importante porque acá
era donde vivían mis padres cecilia
lozano interrumpe su campaña en los
departamentos del meta y guaviare en el
sur oriente de colombia visita a uno de
los múltiples hogares en los que se
refugió víctima del desplazamiento
forzado volver al lugar tiene una gran
carga emocional
algún día me habría gustado
para haber podido contarle todo lo que
yo hice
con la desaparición de su marido cecilia
paso de campesina lideresa y ya lleva 16
años ejerciendo una de las profesiones
de más riesgo en colombia uno sabe que
no lo harían pero yo me atrevo
y me atrevo
sus variadas del vídeo
cecilia de lozano se presenta a las
elecciones transitorias especiales de
paz 16 víctimas de zonas rurales
afectadas por el conflicto en colombia
tendrán representación en la cámara de
representantes
después de más de 5 años regrese a una
vereda rural de su municipio mapiripán
donde en 1999 se produjo una de las
peores masacres paramilitar de la
historia de colombia
en mi historia
así
bueno que hagan escuchaba hablar del
azul de paz durante más de un mes está
visitando acompañada por su esquema de
seguridad y protegida por su sombrero
todas las casas que se encuentran los
políticos tradicionales siempre van y
dan el discurso pero nosotros no somos
políticos de los tradicionales nosotros
somos líderes y nosotros queremos es
escuchar la gente y una de la gente a
ella lo llama jr pedagogía en la primera
vez en la historia de colombia que los
campesinos van a elegir una persona como
usted para ser la voz de las víctimas en
el congreso ella sí ha representado y
vemos el trabajo que ella ha hecho
entonces que es mi voto se va a hacer
para ello lo hace a pesar del riesgo en
2019 la intentaron asesinar a
cuchilladas y durante la campaña la han
estado siguiendo el gobierno debería
financiar su campaña con unos cinco mil
dólares aún no ha recibido nada por lo
que sólo ha podido poner este pasacalles
que le han regalado y del que pese a
todo presume
y cuando me miro así esto yo digo fui
capaz y si me siento orgullosa de mí
mismo de los pasos que yo he dado y
decir yo también puedo
ahora analizamos todo esto que vimos en
el informe de luís muñoz con camilo
gonzález posso él es el presidente del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz camilo gracias por
estar nuevamente con nosotros en france
24 para mí es un gusto volver a
conversar con usted contextualizamos
entonces a nuestra audiencia
internacional y comencemos por hablar
del balance de lo que ha sido la
implementación de estos acuerdos de paz
como se encuentra actualmente el proceso
de paz en el país y que se ha cumplido y
que no
y
estas curules precisamente son una
aplicación del acuerdo de paz
y si tienen muchos puntos tienen seis
capítulos pero desde de ellos se ha
aplicado hasta la fecha del 10 según
observadores internacionales un promedio
de un 20% en algunos temas como los
temas de tierra sobre drogas o de
seguridad pero no se ha avanzado más
allá del 5% de lo que se espera a esta
fecha de modo que
este tema de las curules de paz es una
prueba muy importante porque se ha
buscado darle voz a quienes no han
tenido voz sino que han tenido violencia
historias de guerra en los territorios
es una búsqueda de ampliación de la
democracia entendiendo que la paz es
ante todo ampliación de la democracia
bienestar para la gente y también el
reformas de fondo en la sociedad
colombiana de modo que una gran
expectativa pero también muchas
preocupaciones por el panorama la
debilidad de la implementación de los
acuerdos tiene un capítulo especial en
las dificultades para las
circunscripciones de paz sólo dice que
él 5% de estos acuerdos se han cumplido
o camilo una cifra muy baja teniendo en
cuenta que ya han pasado años desde la
firma de estos acuerdos porque qué es lo
que está pasando además que da garantías
da en este nuevo proceso electoral
colombiano con un nuevo presidente con
un nuevo congreso en el país ya ha
pasado uno anterior de que en esta
oportunidad si se si se sigan cumpliendo
y avance rápidamente
y ha sido muy difícil porque no ha
habido una unidad suficiente en las
élites en el corazón del régimen del
poder político que presentó una fractura
muy fuerte y los opositores al acuerdo
de paz han hecho una resistencia muy muy
grande y han tenido palancas incluso
desde el gobierno de su metro prestado
para solamente aplicar aquellas partes
que les considera adecuadas a sus
programas y a lo que ellos consideran el
mandato del plebiscito donde se dio uno
al primer acuerdo que se ha firmado en
la habana entonces eso pues ha generado
un ambiente muy difícil y bueno este
tema por ejemplo de la ampliación
democrática no solamente ha tenido
dificultades para la circunscripción
especial de paz sino para la reforma
política tenemos un sistema electoral en
colombia
caracterizado por historias de
corrupción e incluso alertas de
corrupción para las tropas actuales de
campañas y las de la votación que se va
a hacer el 13 de marzo y el 27 de mayo
para el congreso 1 y para presidente
otra
no se hizo una reforma para darle
transparencia hay demandas juicios
debates e investigaciones que muestran
que está habido a una maquinaria de
corrupción que por lo tanto tiene que
haber un ejercicio democrático de
vigilancia muy fuerte camilo el rol de
los acuerdos de paz específicamente en
estos comicios que se nos vienen en
colombia
pues la verdad que no solamente son las
curules y
está en juego el que el nuevo congreso
de la república y el nuevo gobierno en
la presidencia se comprometa con la paz
tanto con los acuerdos como que seguir
adelante esos acuerdos son limitados
además hay que reconstruir un consenso
porque abrir una fractura muy fuerte en
la sociedad colombiana de modo que uno
de los elementos que se está jugando en
la paz y en este mundo tan agradecido
con mayor razón adquirir todos los
factores internacionales también pesan y
de modo que el colocar a la paz la
necesidad de superar dinámica de
violencia mediante transformaciones
estructurales de fondo solucionar los
problemas del hambre la crisis de la
pandemia todo eso son cosas son
componentes de una estrategia que debe
llevar la paz más allá de los acuerdos
pero por supuesto tomando esos acuerdos
que son mandato constitucional mandato
legal que es un compromiso ante la
comunidad internacional no se pueden
desconocer pero las elecciones son
fundamentales para su revalidación
política y para la construcción de
nuevos escenarios priorizan a colombia
transitar definitivamente hacia un
escenario de paz tenemos en colombia en
circuitos de recomposición de grupos
armados
permanentes amenazas a la vida de la
gente una campaña electoral que se está
haciendo con inseguridad grave en por lo
menos
250 municipios según la misma defensoría
del pueblo la misión de observación
electoral no tiene que verse como algo
que es un reto para la paz también
porque se recrudece la violencia camilo
en esta víspera de las elecciones en un
país tan polarizado y tan violento como
colombia además el asesinato de los
líderes sociales que parece no parar
si desafortunadamente en colombia
tenemos una larga historia de uso de las
armas en la política del uso de la
intimidación de la amenaza no solamente
para la política para los negocios para
la acumulación de riqueza este no aquí
no ha habido una democracia transparente
ni una economía de mercado que ha habido
un poder político legal e ilegal
disputando los espacios de la vida
social y en las campañas electorales en
las coyunturas electorales
desafortunadamente se ha exacerbado esa
lucha porque entienden quienes quieren
optar capturar el estado más vías e
intereses de camarillas todo tipo de
preparador de clientela entienden que
controlar el congreso de la república
controlar la presidencia controlar
entidades del estado a nivel territorial
es un elemento fundamental para sus
propósitos corruptos y de perpetuación
de este sistema de violencia en colombia
es que llevamos 70 años entre guerras
violencias conflictos armados volviendo
al congreso colombiano que pueda
esperarse entonces de estos los cupos
especiales de la paz en el hemiciclo
pues se ha generado una gran expectativa
y una gran esperanza se dio al principio
de que esto permitirá a la voz de la
gente de más victimizada de las
comunidades más golpeadas
el congreso de la república va a cambiar
y yo creo que ahí van a representarse
una voz de transformación positiva hay
un crecimiento de las voces democráticas
pero también un poderío muy grande de
quienes se oponen a la democracia en la
paz ahí por ejemplo
amenazas de estas 16 curules a están por
lo menos 10
seriamente amenazadas para ser
capturadas no por en contra de las
víctimas y de las comunidades
victimizadas y a favor de clientes de
las de aparatos de mafias e incluso de
gente vinculada al paramilitarismo que
está siendo respaldada y están haciendo
campaña en varias regiones del país de
modo que tenemos una gran incertidumbre
de que este experimento que debería ser
para darle voz a las víctimas a la
democracia desde lo más lejano
imaginados de colombia se convierta en
un resultado
y perverso es decir el lugar de víctimas
tengamos victimarios y es que se lo
quería preguntar porque también a usted
no solamente es el que lo ha dicho sino
que hay varias personas pues que
analizan la política colombiano que
dicen que realmente hay corrupción en
estas 16 curules de paz porque realmente
por qué está pasando esto es triste que
luego de unos acuerdos de paz buscando
pues la paz en un país tan golpeado por
una guerra de más de 70 años como usted
también lo dijo pues esto tan simbólico
se convierta en algo tan feo como como
la corrupción
si estás estas zonas son 170 municipios
los municipios que han tenido historias
más violentas en colombia algunos de
ellos en zonas dispersas rurales de
difícil acceso de la
movilidad se da por ruidoso de todas
maneras en medios muy costosos
las y los candidatos como los escuchamos
ahora a esta líder
no tienen financiación la financiación
estatal que estaba prevista llegó
tardísimo para la gente tuvieron trabas
para abrir una cuenta bancaria todo tipo
de problemas de fondos insuficientes en
cambio quienes están ligados a las
mafias y que en esos territorios quieren
mantener allí sus controles pues sí
tienen facilidades recursos
y sobre todo el constreñimiento al
elector pero hay mucha amenaza y el
propio día de las elecciones quien va a
contar con los recursos para movilizar
por ríos y en el transporte cuando no
sea garantiza un transporte público como
debería ser haberse garantizado que el
estado deba movilizar absolutamente a
todos los electores y va a garantizar
así un experimento distinto donde no
fueron la prueba de las de la
circulación de dineros legales e
ilegales lo que permitiera el acceso a
las urnas de modo que después ese es el
la tragedia que tenemos por supuesto que
hay gente muy valiente a él y su
liderazgo social extraordinario que se
está abriendo camino y que seguramente
también vayan en vocería en esas
circunscripciones especiales de paz lo
importante es eso que a pesar de la
adversidad de todas esas maquinarias hay
gente hay liderazgos hay organizaciones
que quieren hacerse en sentir y eso
también motiva las amenazas lo hace
cuando vemos que matan líderes en esas
regiones es porque están muy organizados
porque les tornan demasiado a los
intereses de quienes siempre han hecho
la guerra y que están interesados esos
ilícitos
camilo rápidamente tenemos a 30 segundos
ya para finalizar a nuestra conversación
usted ve en estos candidatos a la nueva
política colombiana digámoslo así estas
nuevas elecciones voluntad política de
seguir con la paz
pues la verdad que yo soy un poco
ingenuo en mi optimismo pero yo si veo
que la mayor parte de los candidatos
están hablando de paz hay una diferencia
en estas elecciones de las anteriores en
elecciones anteriores las voces
estridentes por la guerra de las más
notorias algo tiene que significar
esperemos que para positivo esperemos
que así sea camilo claro que sí
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros cn francés 24 un gran abrazo
camilo pero sólo estábamos conversando
con camilo gonzález posso presidente el
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz continué en france 24